hello everyone we're glad you've joined
us for this live
webinar a complete workflow for analysis
of cf dna from plasma to variants
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website
and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning
is brought to you by beckmann coulter
and integrated dna technologies
to learn more about our sponsors please
visit them at www.beckman.com
and ibtdna.com
so let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind
so to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click
the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
your presentation window
if you experience any technical problems
seeing or hearing this presentation
just click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the question
and answer box located on the far left
of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process for obtaining
those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speakers
chopa perak a senior application
scientist in
automation and biotechnology business
unit at
beckmann culture life scientist and
nicole roseman
a research scientist at idt
welcome shopa and nicole you may now
begin
your presentations welcome again
okay thank you
in this webinar we will review why
liquid biopsies are challenging
what is conversion mgs workflow
and automation overview with beckman's
apostle minimax high efficiency
isolation kit x-gen prism dna library
prep kit
and x-gen hybridization capture reagents
we will demonstrate an integrated
reagent workflow
for cell-free dna analysis maximizing
cell free dna recovery
from low volumes of plasma higher
conversion and complexity
sensitive and reliable variant calling
at less than one percent allele
frequency
and high on target rates
liquid biopsies such as a blood draw are
much less invasive than tissue biopsies
so if you see the person here on the
left hand side
um theoretically all metastasic sites
are shedding into the bloodstream
representing the full tumor
heterogeneity
better than a localized biopsy sample
cell free dna can provide highly
personalized monitoring
including therapeutic predictive and
prognostic information
by being able to collect multiple
samples over time
why is conversion critical to liquid
biopsy analysis
so conversion is critical because losses
can occur at different points in the
workflow
you see on the right hand side in the
dark blue
the workflow steps include poor recovery
from plasma during extraction
low conversion and loss of coverage
during library prep
loss of complexity and low on target
during high capture
and finally errors that occur during pcr
and sequencing
all of this can lead to a poor limit of
detection
when looking for low frequency variance
limit of detection is important
in accurate identification low yield
and losses throughout the workflow
decrease confidence in the data
consume precious sample and may require
repeating the prep
why is conversion important so let's
um start here with your at the very top
you have your input material your sample
you have your variant of interest
in the dark gray that has a little red
nick in it this is like searching for a
needle in a haystack
you need all of your molecules and
cannot afford loss
so if you go over to the right arrow for
low conversion
low conversion gives you a library with
lower complexity you may lose your
variant of interest as you see with no
dark gray with rednecks and then moving
down again with the arrow
for low coverage low library complexity
also results in fewer reads mapping to
that region
lower coverage decreases sensitivity
so going following your sample with high
conversion on the left
the dark gray or the dark blue arrow
whereas when you have high conversion
giving you high library complexity
you retain your variant of interest as
you see in the
dark gray with the redneck and
going down to higher coverage not only
have you captured your variant
but you also have higher coverage and
thus higher sensitivity
conversion is critical for somatic
mutation detection
clinical samples are often challenging
because not only are they invasive
but they result in small amounts of dna
where cell-free dna
is limited to maybe only a few 1000
genomic equivalents
so looking in at this table on the left
hand side you see that large pieces of
tissue samples
with resections and excisional biopsies
have a high success rate and target
enrichment test
and this column is labeled test
completed successfully with the
percentage
however you see samples
drop below this 50 success rate from
core biopsies
and fine needle aspiration due to not
being able to get enough dna
if the tissue heterogeneity does not
have the variant you want
going back to the patient can be painful
cell-free dna through liquid biopsies is
less painful and if you can increase
conversion
you can increase your success rate so
shoza here will
discuss how to address the conversion
challenge
thanks nickel and thank you all from
beckman coder and idt for attending the
webinar today
so we just heard from nicole why
conversion is important
in this segment we are going to see how
we are addressing this challenge
this workflow is our approach to address
the this challenge
the samples are extracted using apostle
minimax high efficiency dna isolation
technology by beckman coulter
followed by library prep by idt's newly
launched prism dna kit
the libraries are then taken through
idt's hybridization and capture workflow
and then sequenced on illumina's next c
platform
cf dna is of clinical relevance as it
helps in early detection of cancer or
tumor regression
apostle's high efficiency cf dna kit can
be used to extract dna
from large volumes of sample like plasma
serum urine etc
for the automated application it can
extract up to
from four mils of sample and manually
from a maximum of five mils
the kit is compatible with several blood
collection tubes
it supports flexible input and is
automation friendly
another very important benefit is the
possible minimax efficiently removes pcr
inhibitor
to allow for use in ngs and pcr-based
assays
this data is from qpcrsa and shows the
yields
for low and high input volumes between
different kits
at low inputs the yields are comparable
but at high volumes
apostle yields are higher than the other
kids
this is a bioanalyzer trace with agilent
high sensitivity
dna chip for rep replicates from a
parcel and another kit
and the traces show higher yield for cf
dna extracted
from a puzzle kit
figure on the top right shows a
comparison of keels
from samples collected in different
kinds of tubes
three different tubes were tested the
edta tube
streck and pax gene tube the yields are
higher
with a parcel for all the three tube
types
kit a still has some yield but lower
than apostle extracted cf dna
but kit b did not have any yield from
non-edta tubes
the last figure represents the
comparison of pcr inhibition
undiluted samples were compared to
samples diluted in 1 is to 4 ratio
to measure the effect of pcr inhibitors
if pcr inhibitors are present then the
estimated concentration
will be higher in more dilute samples
and if there are comparable
concentrations from dilute and
non-dilute then it's a sign of low
inhibition
as you can see a possible mini max and
supplier 1
have low inhibition and significant pcr
inhibition
is seen in supplier training
in the left image blood samples were
drawn from four healthy donors
in k2 edta tubes the plasma was
harvested by centrifugation
and cfdna was extracted using a parcel
kit
and suppliers a cfdna kit
the cfdna yields were assayed by qpcr
apostle yielded about 25 percent
more cfdna than supplier a it
indicates that a possible minimax has
consistently higher extraction
performance
in the figure on the right it's a tape
station trace
from donor b tf dna size distribution
was analyzed on agilent high sensitivity
d5000 screen tape cfdna extracted from
apostle minimax
has typical mononucleosome peaks at 175
base pair
and dinucleosome peak at the 350 base
pair mark
with a high efficiency compared to
supply array
clearly the cfdna quality and
performance is better for a possible
minimax kit
with that i am handing it back to nicole
to take you through ideating's case
study
thank you
for idt's extern prism dna library kit
let's just dive into that it provides
sensitive
and accurate variant detection from
degraded samples such as cell free dna
and ffpe extern prism gets higher
conversion rates
compared to ta ligation based methods
through use of an engineered ligase and
highly modified adapters
these adapters have a single
concentration regardless of input type
or mass creating an easy workflow
you can get data from even the most
degraded samples
and detect variants at less than or
equal to one percent variant allele
frequency
from libraries with higher yield and
complexity
this minimizes your sequencing errors
with unique molecular indexes
and minimize sample misassignment with
unique dual indexing primers
traditional ta ligation library prep
kits
are less efficient than blunt ligations
however they prevent adapter dimers
and as you see in the box to the left
they also prevent insert to insert
ligation chimeras
adapter dimers are full-length adapters
that can bind and are able to cluster on
flow cells during sequencing
and this is shown with the green and
light blue
let's walk through the mechanism of
idt's xgen prism dna library prep kit
at the beginning input dna should be
fragmented with mechanical shearing
such as via okavara system cell free dna
is already fragmented to the appropriate
size
the end repair enzyme mix converts input
dna
into blunt-ended dna ready for ligation
which you see with um below the arrow
next the ligation one enzyme catalyzes
the single stranded addition
of the ligation one adapter to the three
prime ends of the insert
the three prime end of the l1 adapter
contains a blocking group to prevent
adapter dimer formation
which you see here in the picture
there's a little red circle with an x
through it
this also allows for a fixed
concentration of adapter
and no longer requires a size selection
producing higher conversion
and library complexity when compared to
traditional ta ligation library prep
methods
additionally six single stranded umi
sequences
are added to the insert which you see in
dark blue
and light green and they're labeled with
a umi
this unique single stranded ligation to
fixed umis
enables strand specific molecular
indexing
by independently tagging the top and
bottom strands
the ligation 2 adapter acts as a primer
to gap fill the bases
complementary to the umi which you see
in the dark blue
and lime green arrows going inward
towards the insert
this is followed by ligation at the
fry's prime end
of the dna insert to create a double
stranded product
ready for pcr amplification
pcr incorporates sample index sequences
our xgen unique dual indexing primer
pairs
minimize sample misassignment
after x-gen prism libraries have been
cleaned up in qc'd we take
500 nanograms of library into target
capture
x-gen blocking oligos are added and bind
to library adapter sequences
to reduce the off target being captured
and prevent daisy cheating
you see here the blocking oligos are the
dark blue
in the middle fragments probes which are
the light blue
hybridized to your target of interest
probes are five prime biotin
attimulated and pulled down via
streptavidin beads
idt offers two different types of panels
the first are
xgen lockdown probes these are
individually synthesized
q seed and normalized prior to pooling
they're also also customizable and
modular
the second are ngs discovery pools which
have the fastest turnaround time
for fifty thousand pro for less than
fifty thousand probes
the turnaround time is five days these
have high fidelity and are also
individually synthesized
idt synthesis and chemistry gets you the
on target
coverage and uniformity during ultra
deep sequencing
which i will show data on in the
subsequent slides
so going into an experiment that we
conducted cell-free dna conversion was
evaluated using beckman's apostle
minimax extraction kit
and it was compared across three
different library prep kits
ours the x-gen prism kit a and kit b
all of the libraries generated were
captured in sequence using the same
method
a key performance metric to evaluate
library prep is ligation efficiency
so taking a look at the graph on the
x-axis you have your yield
in input into library prep and then on
the y-axis
is your ligation efficiency idt's
ligation strategy is more efficient than
traditional ta ligation-based meth
based methods for 100 nanogram of
genomic dna input
xgen prism has approximately two times
the ligation efficiency
while 25 nanogram input is approximately
three times higher than kit a
and kit b ligation efficiency was
measured via qpcr after ligation 2.
ligation efficiency is just one part of
conversion
stringent bead cleanups pcr efficiency
and hybrid capture
all affect conversion
so extern prism dna library prep kits
have higher conversion and complexity
with cell-free dna
so looking at the graph on the left the
x-axis
is the library prep kit and on the y
axis is conversion rate measured
after sequencing and all the reads were
normalized to be comparable between the
three library prep kits
xgen prism libraries have approximately
three times higher conversion
when compared to kit a and kit b with 25
nanograms
input of cell-free dna moving to the
graph on the right
again you see the library prep kit on
the x-axis
and on the y-axis are the unique
molecules measured after sequencing
xgen prism libraries have approximately
three times higher the number of unique
molecules
than kit a or kit b
now i have data from a case study with
cell free dna from healthy donors
the libraries here were generated
according to many
each manufacturer's protocol using 25
nanograms of cell free dna
so looking at the infographic cartoon on
the left hand side
samples a and b were drawn from two
healthy donors
into k2 edta tubes
four mils of plasma was harvested by
centrifugation
and cell free dna was extracted using
the apostle minimax high efficiency
isolation kit
sample b was spiked into sample a to
create an allele
frequency of 0.25 percent
libraries were then captured with a
custom 61kb
xgen lockdown probe panel and analyzed
with start stop to duplication
variants were called using verdict or
combined read family error correction
sensitivity and positive productive
value
were also measured
so using the abstracted cell-free dna
all things equal input same extraction
extend prism performs better than ka the
left graph compares library complexity
while the graph on the right compares
start coverage
again sequencing reads were normalized
between both library prep kits
increasing your conversion increases
your library
complexity and thus your performance
okay high on target rates and uniformity
even from small capture panels as our 61
kb
action lockdown probe panel using
the graph farthest on the left you see
that it gets high on target even for
both library prep kits
x-gen prism and kit a however moving on
to the middle
graph if comparing coverage using
combined read families
on the y-axis is your target base
fraction and that's the percent of bases
that get to at least that level of
coverage
the graph farthest on the right compares
coverage using start and stop
here we demonstrate how efficient
capture with high complex libraries from
x-gen prism
lead to higher coverage efficient
captures
have high on target rates and uniformity
and all
of this enables a better ability to call
variants
digging into how we use umi-based error
correction and data analysis
so recall a fixed single stranded umi
sequence
was added to your library insert during
ligation one
which enables strand specific molecular
indexing
by independently tagging the top and
bottom strands
the one of 32 possible sequences
on either side which is demonstrated
with the dark blue
and lime green umi label give you enough
diversity
because the umi sequences are fixed even
if there are errors in the umi
it is possible to identify and correct
these errors
which prevent artificial inflation of
library complexity
so comparing data analysis with versus
without umis
first let's look at analysis without umi
you have your original dna
fragment on the farthest left and the
little green circles are your true
positive mutation
moving through your workflow you get
errors introduced
such as through sequencing or through
pcr
and else the output is your sequencing
data
moving on to the right you get
duplication by start stop
position and this goes with the highest
quality read
and it might not contain your variant
so when you do analysis with umis
again on the farthest left looking at
your original dna fragments
the little green circles are your true
positive mutation
but the colored ends are umis and
they're added during x-gen prism dna
library preparation
going through the workflow again just
like we did before and the little red
circles
are your pcr or sequencing errors
so with the sequencing data the shaded
regions represent read families before
consensus regeneration
using both the start stop position and
umi sequence
to deduplicate reads this method uses
all sequencing data
from the read family to choose the most
likely base at each position
from beginning to end this can be done
with single read families
or combined read families so looking
under error correction with umis and
focusing on single read families
these use umis on one strand
you see one error still sneaks through
then going over to combined reed
families these use the umis on both
strands resulting in less false
positives
and increasing specificity you need this
high specificity and sensitivity
for limit of detection and this is done
by our high conversion
after sequencing reads were mapped using
vwa
start stop deduplication or error
correction across
both strands were performed so this is
the same libraries from our case study
that we went over
and it was captured with the custom 61kb
extern lockdown pro panel
they reliably identify less than one
percent variance with umi-based error
correction
so using umi based error correction
dramatically increases variant calling
accuracy
while still maintaining great
sensitivity percentage
this also greatly decreases the chances
of false positive calls
we have demonstrated an integrated
workflow for cell-free dna
using a complete reagent workflow that
guarantees high conversion
this maximizes cell-free dna recovery
from low volumes of plasma
and obtains higher conversion and
complexity using the xgen prism dna
library prep kit
and produces sensitive and reliable
variant calling at less than one percent
allele frequency
using built-in fixed umis i'll now
turn it back over to shopa to dive into
automation
thanks nicole as you saw that ngs
workflows are complex
so along with idt beckman coulter has
designed a complete end-to-end
automated solution to address customers
pain points
improve library quality increase
throughput and faster turnaround time
with least hands-on time are important
components for successful results
here i'm showcasing the automated
solutions for a possible extraction kit
idt's x gen prism dna library prep kit
and idt's high capture kit
we are constantly trying to understand
how to help customers in expediting
their research
by adapting to varied workflows and
providing
time and cost savings and quality
results and support
our solutions are flexible and scalable
easy to implement with support from our
experienced
applications team
along with implementing recent
innovations on hardware and software
the primary function of the biomac
workstation remains providing accurate
and reproducible pipetting performance
we offer two sizes of i-series automated
liquid handling workstations
with either 45 or 25 depth positions
and six different pipetting
configurations to meet your throughput
and application needs these workstations
can be open
or enclosed we have three different
multi-channel heads and different
syringe sizes for span8 probes
we listen to the feedback given by
customers these themes led to a common
foundation
across multiple applications for
hardware software
accessories consumables and support the
bio makai series is simplified so you
can focus
more on the science and less on managing
your tools
with multi-color status light bar and
light curtain for safety
it's efficient to help you optimize
productivity
increase walk away time with larger deck
capacity
independent 360 degree grippers and
large multi-channel head
it's reliable to help maximize
instrument up time
systems have two cameras and also come
with beckman connect remote service
support
and it's adaptable so the technology you
invest in can grow with you
with grid-based design and standard
device integrations
applications developed at bettencoulter
are demonstrated
which means they are written optimized
tested with samples and then they are
ready to install at a customers lab
with faster implementation along with
the great pipetting performance with the
hardware
we also provide the user friendly biomix
software with demonstrated methods
interface tools
these are set of tools we utilize in
these methods to provide
ease of use for the operator to run
complex workflows
so the dmi includes biomech method
launcher
method option selector guided labware
setup
and dec optics final check
biomec method launcher software is
designed specifically with the system
operator in mind
the launcher presents the biomec methods
that are meant to be run by the operator
from an app style screen
method option selector provides the
runtime options to schedule the daily
experiments
guided labware setup is one of our
advanced deck setup utility
it guides the user through deck setup by
labware type
and volume with advanced support for
labview stacking and reagent preparation
and deck optics final check identifies
the problem before the start
of the experiment further taking you
through each of these tools
methods are run by biomech method
launcher to avoid the risk of editing
the biomet methods accidentally
the methods can be run from an app style
screen and deck setup notes
and master mix recipes can be printed to
keep for your records
no need to navigate the core software as
the team can as the system can be run
from bml without
unintentionally editing the biomec
methods
the method option selector or mos is an
interactive user interface
written keeping the modular workflow in
mind with all of the recommended start
stop points in the ifu
here i'm showing the user interface for
all the three applications
for extraction user can choose number of
samples
input volume illusion volume etc
the prism library prep kit has sample
number input
on deck or off deck thermo cycling on
deck normalization
and all the sections of the library prep
the method can be run as full walk away
or modular on i7
for hybridization both dry down and
ampule bead-based concentration
protocols
are supported hype can be done on deck
or off deck and capture can be done on
the on deck with the help of multiple
peltiers
guided labrador setup helps set the deck
correctly
and organizes details on labware and
reagents
and leads you through your deck setup
step by step it provides
detailed instructions for type of
labware its placement on the desk
and each reagent position and volume
based on the options choose chosen in
mos
on the right you see the stock reagent
tubes on the cold block
this this is a modular reservoir with
bulk reagents
and here's the final deck setup
the dynamic method automatically adjust
labware quantity
and reagent volumes based on variable
sample number
human error is a part of science there
are a lot of components that get added
to the deck
so it's easy to make mistakes with the
help of left
and right cameras on biomec deck optics
final check helps
identify common errors that can result
in wasting expensive chemistry
failed experiments and delayed projects
final check ensures that you place your
labware
in the correct location and provide
warnings if lab wear is missing
or if the wrong tip type or plate types
are detected on the deck
as in the example you can see deck
optics recognize that wrong tips are
placed at two positions
thus saving the experiment
moving into each application apostle
minimax is automation amenable and
scalable the market requires higher
throughput
extraction to expedite the downstream
research
and automation plays a key role in
achieving a target
a powerful minimax cfdna kit is
automated on both biomac i5
and i7 workstations the i5 multi-channel
has a throughput of 48 samples which can
be extracted
in less than five hours the i7 hybrid
application
is designed for a throughput of max 96
samples
extracted in a little over 5 hours for 4
mils of sample
both the decks are equipped with orbital
shaker peltiers and incubator
and can extract from one to four mils of
sample
the following is the data from biomec i7
application
four mils of plasma was used to extract
cf dna
for three technical reps of seven
different donors
four of the donors were from edta tubes
and three were from tax gene
on the left is comparison of qpcr traces
for manual and automated extracted
samples
on the right of the ct value comparison
and we can see they are pretty
comparable with the manual workflow
we also compared the cfdna yields for
manual and automated samples via
picogreen assay and the yields are
comparable
or higher for automated workflow
the last one is a comparison of
extracted cfdna from different types of
tubes
the blue traces are manual and red
traces are for automated
extracted cf dna and the results look
quite comparable
this is the deck layout for idtx
generism
and idtx gen height capture automated
solutions
the deck layout has been kept same for
smooth transition between running both
the applications
each application supports a throughput
of 96 samples
with the help of atc wash stations
shaker
and peltier one peltier helps keep the
reagents cold and the other two peltiers
help keep the reaction plate chilled
during library prep
or keep the buffers heated during
capture
normalization of sample is also
supported on deck
in the following figures the white
square is the deck setup and the yellow
time symbol is the recommended safe stop
points
this is a flowchart showing how
automated application is handled on i7
the automated pro protocol for prism is
a full walk away solution once the deck
is set up using guided setup
but it is flexible to run modularly so
users can plan their day
it starts at normalization and final
library is ready after the pcr cleanup
this is the workflow for hybridization
capture as automated on i7
after initial deck setup the application
can run blocking and dry down
or ampure bead-based concentrating
protocol
hybridization can be done on deck or off
deck
from four hours to overnight after hype
deck is reset to
replenish all the reagents and tips to
carry on capture
pcr and last cleanup
here's a table to show instrument setup
time and run time for different sections
of the protocol for prism dna library
prep kit
the fully automated method can prepare
96 libraries in around 5 hours
with only 20 minutes of hands-on time
whereas the hands-on time for manually
preparing 24 libraries is around 2 hours
and on the right is hands-on time and
turnaround times for height capture
protocol
for 96 capture using bead-based
concentration and 4-hour hybridization
the captures can be done in less than 10
hours
the hands-on time is three and a half
hours for 32 samples prepared manually
versus 45 minutes hands-on time to set
the deck for automation
we have several resources like
application notes
overview flyers and posters available
for apostle cf dna extraction solution
and idt's x-gen hybridization and
capture
which covers the experimental design and
data in detail and are available upon
request
the xgen prism dna library prep project
is currently in final stages of sample
testing
and will be available soon
to conclude this is an end-to-end
automated solution from extraction to
captured libraries
ready to be loaded on illumina
sequencers
automation helps to reduce hands-on time
and increase throughput
the higher throughput supports more
barcodes and allows for multiplexing
and full utilization of sequencers the
kits are automation friendly and
scalable
and automation supports bead best based
technology
for extraction and cleanups with
enhanced selective tip pipetting for a
faster turnaround
demonstrated methods interface tools
provide correct depth setup
and reduction in setup errors with
automation the cross contamination can
be avoided
and helps in accurate and precise sample
transfers
the solutions are supportable by
knowledgeable teams from idt
and beckmann coulter
with that we thank you again for
attending this webinar
and thank you shelba and nicole for that
presentation and for your important
research
we will now start the live q a session
of the webinar a quick reminder of for
our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them into the drop
down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window
labeled ask a question and click that
send button
chopa and nicole will answer as many
questions as time permits
so let's take a look at our questions
coming in from our audience members
shoba nicole our first question is how
are the umis being used in error
correction
um i can take that question and let me
go back up to one of my previous slides
since it has a nice
infographic to explain
this
okay so here is the infographic
kind of showing how umi can be used for
error correction
remember here on the ends the color
nice pretty colors are they represent
the um eyes
so umis are on single and on both
strands and they can be used to create
single read families or combine read
families
so consensus reads are then generated
and
aligned based on either single or
combined read families
rather than using the highest quality
read you are using
all of your sequencing data within your
read family and this
collects the most likely base at each
position from beginning to end
so combined read families takes the step
for a step
further and compares both strands
thank you for that and what what are
what are the advantages of
fixed umis over random umis
yes that's a good question um fixed umis
enable strand specific molecular
indexing
because they independently independently
tag the top
and bottom strands so even if a pcr
or sequencing error does occur within
the umi
it's possible to identify and correct
for these errors
preventing artificial library complexity
thank you for that and again i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in
our next question coming in it says how
do indexing primers prevent
sample misassignment
so the experiment that i shared today
uses
unique dual indexing primers so
udis contain unique index sequencing
or sequences for both the i5 and i7
index reads of the illumina sequencing
platform
so misassigned reads will be flagged as
undetermined
and then they're excluded from analysis
thank you for that and what are typical
yields after a possible extraction
from a tube of blood for example four
millimeters of plasma
this is shilpa and i can take this one
cf dna concentrations actually vary
significantly
they can range from one nanogram to 100
nanograms per ml of plasma
but the concentration typically seen for
cfdna for healthy donors is usually
between
1 to 15 nanograms per ml of plasma
thank you shopa and we have time for a
few more questions
that are coming in can an audience
member wants to know can i use the
prison um kit with t
a ligation adapters or other
idt adapters
um yeah um so i know idt does a lot of
custom
designs for people but in this case you
cannot
so the adapters that are supplied in the
x-gen prism kit
have been optimized to enhance ligation
efficiency
so these adapters in combination with
our engineered ligase
is why our conversion rates are so high
so and then plus an added benefit
is you don't have to mess with adjusting
the concentration
based on your sample input and during
the presentation
you talked about the dec optic software
what errors does that detect
so once the deck is set up using guided
labware setup
the dual cameras on biomec will help
using the dec optic final check software
and that will detect
wrong plate type or wrong tip box type
or if any labware is missing from that
particular setup
thank you for that we have time for one
more question
there is gdna contamination
in a lie of apostle minimax how do you
prevent
that from happening
so the improper handling of blood can
result in gdna contamination
delay in processing of these tubes and
especially in the edta tubes will cause
cell lysis and gdna releasing into
plasma
the incomplete removal of these cellular
components can also result in gdna
contamination and frozen whole blood can
also cause significant cell breakage and
gdna contamination so if you know
avoided these steps then the gdna
contamination will be less in the sample
thank you again shilpa and nicole for
your presentation
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions as a
reminder any questions we do not have
time for today will be addressed by the
speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of the registration
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
beckmann culture life sciences and
integrated dna technologies
for underwriting today's educational
webcasts
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time
bye